what I want to do in this video is prove
the change of base formula for
logarithms change of base change of base
formula which tells us write this
formula formula which tells us that if I
want to figure out the logarithm base a
base a of X base a of X that I can
figure this out by taking logarithms
with a different base that this could be
that this would be equal to the
logarithm logarithm base B so some other
base base B of X base B of X divided by
divided by the logarithm base B base B
of a base B of A and this is a really
useful result if your calculator only
has natural logarithm or log base ten
you can now use this to figure out the
logarithm using any base if you want to
figure out the log base two let me make
it clear if you want to figure out the
logarithm base let's say base three of
let's say 25 you can use your calculator
either using log base 10 or log base 2
so you could say that this is going to
be equal to log base 10 log base 10 of
25 and most calculators have a button
for that divided by divided by log base
10 divided by log base 10 of 3 log base
10 of 3 so this is an application of the
change of base formula but let's
actually prove it so let's say that
let's say that we want it let's let's
set logarithm logarithm base a of X base
a of X to be equal to some new variable
let's call that variable let's call that
equal to Y so this right over here we
are just setting that equal to Y well
this is just another way of saying that
a to the Y power is
to X so we can rewrite this as a to the
Y power a to the Y power is equal to is
equal to X and I'll write the X out here
because I'm about to these two things
are equal this is just another way of
restating what we just wrote up here now
let's introduce the logarithm base B and
to introduce it I'm just gonna take log
base B of both sides of this equation so
let's take a logarithm base B of the
left-hand side and a logarithm base B
logarithm base B of the right-hand side
well we know from our logarithm
properties that the logarithm of
something to a power is the exact same
thing as the power times the logarithm
of that something so logarithm base B of
a to the Y is the same thing as Y times
the logarithm the logarithm base B of a
so this is just a traditional logarithm
property we proved it elsewhere and we
already know it's going to be equal to
the right hand side it's going to be
equal to log base B log base B of X and
now let's just solve for y and this is
exciting because why was this thing
right over here but now if we solve for
y we're gonna be solving for y in terms
of logarithm base B to solve for y we
just have to divide both sides of this
both sides of this equation by log base
B of A so we divide by log base B of a
of a on the left hand side and we divide
by log base B base B of a on the right
hand side and so on the left hand side
these two characters are going to cancel
out and we are left with and we deserve
a drum roll now that Y y is equal to log
base B of X divided by log base B of A
so let me write it just copy and paste
this so I don't have to keep switching
colors so let me paste this so there you
have it you have your change of base
formula remember Y is the same thing
this thing right over here why is log of
a actually let me make it clear why
which is equal to log of a which is
equal to log base a of X so copy and
paste Y which is equal to this thing
from which is how we defined it right
over here Y is equal to log base a of X
is we've just shown is also equal to
this if we write it in terms of base if
we write it in terms of base B and we
have our change of base formula